then what do you have you have a hashtag
believe all women hashtag me too I mean
you know every time like how many women
empowerments groups are there how many
hashtag boss babe where do you hear like
boss dude like boss man like where
where's the boss man movement right what
Andrew Tate started one and he's in
prison you know like there is no so I
don't I don't think it is disingenuous
to look at there's a gigantic imbalance
and again it goes back to like who are
the ones that use social media most
women women who are the ones that are
the largest part of the voting block
women who spends the most of the
consumer money women who spends the most
amount of uh College loan debts in the
United States America women you know so
when you look at the whole picture it
does seem like it's just a disingenuous
manipulation I'm not saying that bad
things don't happen women from men
certainly do but there's also bad things
that happen to men from women we're just
choosing to highlight and demonize men
and